Ми точно не будемо зупиняти трансформацію системи охорони здоров’я. Ми не ідіоти.
Як ви оцінюєте діяльність Уляни Супрун?
Немає війни і я сподіваюсь, що пані Уляна так само вважає.
Була зустріч президента з командою МОЗу. Які у Вас враження?
Дозволите мені не коментувати?
Чи буде відкат медреформи? Хто прийде на зміну Уляни Супрун та скільки коштуватимуть ліки.
Про це поговоримо з засновником та колишнім співвласником
ершої приватної клініки «Борис»
радником президента України Михайлом Радуцьким.
Пане Михайле, доброго дня!
Пане Михайло, Вас вперто називають претендентом на пост Міністра охорони здоров’я,
можливо, через ваші публічні суперечки з Уляною Супрун.
Суперечки з Уляною Супрун? У мене їх немає.
Але я точно не Міністр охорони здоров’я.
Але Ви так само заперечували свою посаду на пост голови
Комітету ВР з питань охорони здоров’я.
По-перше, я не заперечував, по-друге, ще рада присягу не прийняла,
як можна про це сказати, за те, що ще не відбулось.
Єдине, що я не заперечую і після указу я це підтверджую,
бо вийшов указ, так я радник Президента України.
А з приводу Вашої посади на посту голови Комітету?
Якщо оберуть, то буду.
Чому Ви не бачите себе на посаді міністра?
Я вважаю, що міністр має бути таким як в США -
це людина, чиє прізвище ніхто не знає.
В США навіть керівники великих лікарень
не знають прізвища Міністра охорони здоров’я.
Завдяки тому, що це не потрібно, бо в країні працює закон.
А якщо працює закон, то міністр перейти межу закону не може.
Він займається ідеологією і це не стосується практичної медицини.
Це функція трошки інша. Там немає політики.
На цій посаді немає політики. Це дуже важливо.
Чим більше міністр буде не публічною і не політичною особою, тим краще для справи.
- Ви вважаєте себе публічною особою?
- Я вважаю себе, на жаль, публічною особою.
Як Ви оцінюєте діяльність Уляни Супрун на посаді міністра?
Ви знаєте, я б не хотів казати про особистості.
Я можу сказати, що те, що зробив Квіташвілі.
По-перше, всі коли кажуть, що щось зробила пані Уляна, всі забувають,
що початок цьому поклав пан Квіташвілі…
Але саме цього хочете і Ви, щоб почав один міністр, продовжив інший, не рубав з коліна…
Так!  Є речі, які зроблені минулим урядом.
Наприклад, минулий Уряд і завдяки пані Уляні
прийняв закон, який писав ще пан Квіташвілі, «Про державні фінансові гарантії»,
то це тільки плюс. Не можна казати, що це погано.
Ми точно не будемо зупиняти трансформацію системи охорони здоров’я.
Ми не ідіоти. Це перше. По-друге,
Ми не будемо ламати те, що вже зроблено і воно працює.
Те, що не зроблене і працює не зовсім вірно - ми зробимо аудит
і ми відкоригуємо деякі речі.
Так, ми кажемо, що у нас є трохи інше системне бачення.
І ми вважаємо, що система охорони здоров’я має бути за страховою моделлю.
Але все, що зроблено минулим урядом, і не тільки цим урядом,
а й декількома минулими урядами, зроблені кроки,
які допоможуть нам зробити загальнодержавне медичне страхування.
Тому не бачу нічого. У нас є питання по лікарському самоврядуванню.
Ми вважаємо, що це помилка, коли МОЗ каже,
що лікар має отримувати ліцензію в МОЗі тільки на три роки.
Немає ніде в світі такого.
Ви Deutsche Welle, поцікавтесь у Німеччині ліцензія видається лікарю на все життя.
І видається не МОЗом, а профільною лікарською асоціацією.
Ми маємо зробити так, щоб у нас  спочатку
прийняли положення, що таке “Лікарська асоціація”,
бо якщо ми завтра скажемо, що лікарська асоціація ліцензує лікарів,
то я гарантую, що у нас буде по декілька тисяч різноманітних асоціацій в кожному напрямку.
Це має бути врегульовано, але в МОЗі має бути можливість для людей апелювати.
Була зустріч теперішньої команди МОЗу із президентом.
Ви були на цій зустрічі?
Які враження були від того, що презентували в МОЗі.
- Дозолите не коментувати це.
- Чому?
Якщо дозволите, я б хотів ні пояснювати, ні коментувати це.
Бо це була зустріч в президента. І я був лише як радник.
А там був президент і в.о. міністра, то коментарі мають надавати вони.
Я, може, не буду об’єктивним.
Не знаю, я не буду цього коментувати.
Було прохання керівництва МОЗу зустрітись з президентом,
і президент не міг, не мав права, відмовити в такій зустрічі.
Як тільки у нього з’явився час, він зробив таку зустріч.
Я не бачу тут ніяких політичних… підґрунть.
Це нормальний робочий процес.
Не кожен міністр хотів зустрічатись з президентом.
Пані Уляна захотіла і їй не відмовили. Так, це не відбулось по дзвінку,
що я сьогодні хочу і президент сьогодні відповів. У президента є ще
багато обов’язків, але президент сказав.. десь два-три тижні пройшло
після того, як пані Уляна запитала про таку зустріч. Президент приділив час,
і ця зустріч була десь не менше години. Я вважаю, що це нормально...
Здається, що вона може бути тим технократом, про яких мріє команда президента...
Не я вирішую, хто буде міністром,
комітет вирішує трохи інші речі.
Давайте спочатку треба уряд обрати, а потім хай вже прем’єр-міністр набирає собі команду.
Пані Уляна це буде, чи не пані Уляна.. мені важко це сказати.
Я вважаю, що це рішення має бути за прем’єр-міністром
і за коаліцією, і за президентом.
У мене таке суб’єктивне відчуття, що це той міністр,
за яким стоїть справді українське громадянське суспільство в Україні...
Ви знаєте, я до пані Уляни... Якщо побачите історію "Бориса",
під час реформи пані Уляни, ми перші хто її підтримав.
Перезавантаження системи ми підтримуємо і надалі.
Але давайте так, Ви бачили результати пана Гройсмана?
От Вам відповідь на питання, яке суспільство кого підтримує, в яких відсотках.
Це ж соціологія, це вже ніхто не вигадує,
це вже вибори закінчились і вже нічого не треба технологічно Вам казати, щоб це було як технологія.
Це представники уряду, людини, яка набрала 2%.
Про яке суспільство Ви мені зараз розповідаєте?
Так? 2% суспільства.
То я Вам скажу, що тоді Богатирьова у наст у суспільства має підтримку.
Партія "Опозиційна платформа - За життя" набрала аж 13%!
але ж Ви не будете зараз мені казати, що Богатирьова це той міністр, який має підтримку суспільства.
Це не особисто до пани Уляни Супрун відноситья. Це взагалі до Кабміну,
бо цей Кабмін був 5 років в країні і ми бачимо результат.
Я розумію, що у нас такі ж самі результати, не дай боже, можуть бути за декілька років.
Я це розумію. Але сьогодні у нас країна,
де головним джерелом влади є народ. І народ сказав своє слово.
Пане Михайле, Ви коли критикуєте медичну реформу....
... я не критикую медичну реформу, де ви таке чули?
Ви говорите про те.. деякі кроки медичної реформи.
Ви говорите про те, що треба зробити перепис населення, тому що
тоді не відомо скільки держава має виділяти грошей на медицину...
І не відмовлюсь від цього, і президент це розуміє,
і наголосив, що ми маємо провести перепис населення.
Наскільки це в команді обговорюється, коли ми можемо очікувати перепис населення?
Наскільки я це чую, то перепис буде проводитись ще в цьому році.
Наскільки я це чую. Але результати будемо мати
це  наступний рік, десь восени наступного року,
ми будемо кінцевий результат мати для того, щоб роботи макроекономічні розрахунки.
Це означає, що в медицині так само буде пауза?
Ні. Чому це так означає? Де Ви це прочитали,
в медицині не буде паузи! Паузу зробили не ми, паузу зробив сьогоднішній МОЗ,
який мав влітку оголосити пілот по діагностиці і вторинці.
Вони відтермінували це. Це не ми відтермінували, це уряд!
Який не виділив фінансування..
Виділили фінансування, але його не вистачило на первинку
і тому зняли з вторинки і виділили на первинку. Чому це відбулось?
Знову ж тих причин, що ми не розуміємо скільки у нас населення,
скільки нам треба грошей. Я думаю, що це одна з причин,
але одна з ненайменших причин.
Тому ніхто нічого не відміняв, є закони України,
і доки не прийняті нові ми не можемо не виконувати старі.
В законі “Про фінансові гарантії” я вважаю,  що була дуже велика помилка
минулого скликання Верховної Ради, що була прибрана норма про співоплату,
я вважаю, що це дуже погано.
І пані Уляна так само вважає. І ми тут сходимось з нею.
Тому, я вам ще раз кажу, якщо ви хочете знайти якусь війну між мною та нею,
чи президентом Зеленським, чи партією “Слугою народу”
з Уляною Супрун, з особистістю, Ви не знайдете, немає війни,
і я сподіваюсь, що пані Уляна так само вважає.
І те, що зробила пані Уляна ми теж цінуємо.
У нас немає чогось такого.. а далі це вже війна заголовків.
Бо пані Уляна не казала, про “расизм”,
але всі пишуть, що Супрун звинуватила Радуцького у расизмі.
Але ось ваша цитата…
Немає там про “расизм”. Ви від пані Уляни чули про расизм?
І я від своєї цитати не відмовлюсь!
“Генетичних відмінностей” і “хвороб у представників різних рас”...
Є таке.  І я не відмовлюсь, бо дійсно, якщо Ви візьмете американські ліки,
чи французькі ліки, то там в деяких анотаціях 100% написано,
що в людей з різними генетичними кодами, з різних рас,
є відмінності по впливу цих ліків.
Але журналістам було цікаво фейканути.
А про “національні протоколи” Ви теж критикували,
що мають послуговуватись не міжнародними.
А в Німеччині як? Запитайте своїх глядачів, чи в Німеччині є міжнародні протоколи,
чи там все ж таки німецькі?
Міжнародних протоколів не існує, є міжнародні настанови.
Протоколи тільки національні. Що в США, що в Молдові,
що, навіть, у Північного сусіда.
І сьогодні я Вам більше скажу, якщо їх не адаптувати,
то наприклад є Інститут нейрохірургії,
давайте приймемо протоколи на рівні Національного інститут нейрохірургії
і що будуть робити лікарі в Житомирській обласній лікарні?
А вони відрізняються дуже сильно. Я про це кажу.
Протокол - це ж не вилікувати, це ж як лікувати покроково.
Наскільки я розумію, що якщо ми говоримо,
що апендицит лікуємо в одних країнах так, то в Україні мають робити так само.
А що хтось каже, щоб прийняти український протокол,
по якому апендицит будемо через горло видаляти?
В тому й річ, про це і йдеться...
Є лікарня в Житомирській області, де немає MRI.
так що ми всі інсульти “повеземо” в Київ, бо в Києві є, а там немає.
Ви як це пропонуєте?
Як ми можемо сьогодні брати протокол,
де в сільській місцевості гелікоптер прилітає в Німеччині,
а в нас доріг немає. Коли там тільки Hyperloop Омеляна може тільки проїхати,
там нічого більше не проїде між Кропивницьким і Кривим Рогом.
Там і Hyperloop навряд проїде.
То про які стандарти ми можемо.. Це наша мрія дійти до стандартів німецьких.
Це так само, як мене звинуватили в тому, що я кажу, що я хочу,
щоб мене звинувачували, що ми зробили медицину в Україні
за застарілою системою Бісмарка, яка працює в Німеччині.
Я так хочу, щоб мене саме в цьому звинувачували. Я хочу, щоб люди казали:
“Ось цей гад, що він зробив, що він зробив таку систему, як в Німеччині!”.
Це система Бісмарка.
Пане Михайле ще кілька слів про комунікацію з МОЗом.
Ви казали, що закупівлю ліків мають здійснювати не міжнародні організації, а українські.
Так, і МОЗ це підтверджує.
Так, підтверджує і каже про те, що вже існує таке підприємство.
Чого воно існує сьогодні, а не три роки тому?
Його минулого року створили.
Воно тільки-тільки починає працювати. В цьому році.
якби його створили минулого року, чому ми на цей рік залишили
закупівлю міжнародним організаціям. Скажіть мені будь аска, ви ж поважні журналісти.
Тому що все відбувається покроково і МОЗ про це каже,  що одразу всі реформи не можна зробити.
Я розумію, але три роки це не два місяці.
А до того ще був Квіташвілі це вже чотири роки.
А до Квіташвілі був Мусій. Це всі майдані міністри.
Це не міністри з минулого життя, це не Богатирьова.
Тобто, на вашу думку, МОЗ діє повільно?
На мою думку, ще в 2015 році прем'єр-міністр Яценюк погодився з паном Квіташвілі,
що треба віддати закупівлі з МОЗу на державну агенцію.
І першу постанову з цього приводу якраз підписував пан Яценюк,
а не Гройсман і не пані Уляна. Але єдине, в чому різниця:
коли це робить державна агенція з українським директором
або з аудитором, або на аутсорсинг...
Моя пропозиція була, що цією установою має керувати на аутсорсингу
якась міжнародна... хтось із першої п'ятірки. Грошей вистачить,
бо сьогодні ми втрачаємо набагато більше,
ніж буде коштувати аутсорсингу BPO чи PwC чи ще когось.
Але це має бути на території України,
людина має відповідати тут, на території України,
бо, при всій повазі до міжнародних організацій, вони не підзаконні державі Україна.
У мене питання: коли українська компанія закупає,
то за законом вона сплачує після дати постачання.
А три роки ми сплачували дуже великі кошти,
а ліки отримували через рік
і чому ми ці гроші не могли в себе в Україні тримати на казначейських рахунках
і заробляти на них ще якісь відсотки, щоб з тих грошей ще більше закупити?
Але ж пам’ятаєте, яка була недовіра до закупівлі ліків.
Не питання, там були відкати. Тому я й кажу:
хай цією конторою керує з першої п'ятірки.
Я не вірю, що BDO дозволить собі взяти відкат.
На сьогодні що ви скажете ЮНІСЕФ чи ще комусь?
Вони тут не знаходяться. Оце мій підхід:
я не проти міжнародних партнерів,
я проти того, щоб ми не втрачали гроші,
бо ми ці гроші могли тримати рік на депозиті.
Це найменша ставка, мені здається, 5-7% від тої суми.
Але це ми зараз так думаємо, коли розуміємо, що закупівлі відбуваються прозоро і чесно.
Раніше ситуація була інакша.
А я не знаю, як вони відбуваються. Прозоро і чесно,
як було раніше і як сьогодні - це питання не до мене.
Це - до силовиків.
Ви знаєте, раніше було щось. Де хоч одна справа?
Я теж знаю і я теж чув,  як ви, що раніше було.
Але сьогодні я чую так само і чому я тоді маю вірити, а сьогодні не маю вірити?
Ну ось нова команда проведе ще й реформу правоохоронних органів
і судів і тоді, можливо, будуть справи.
І дуже добре, що у нас 255 депутатів, що ми не будемо казати,
що це не ми, а що це партнери по коаліції. Це ми.
І мені в цій команді подобається, що ніхто не боїться казати:
це наш обов’язок і ми будемо за це відповідати.
Пане Михайле, Ви були радником мера Києва Віталія Кличка,
у вас дуже добрі стосунки.
Я вам більше скажу, я був заступником мера. Сьогодні я радник,
треба зараз звільнитись, бо закон того вимагає.
Так, я був у 2014 -2015 році.
Ви дуже добре знаєте Віталія Кличка.
Так. Я ніколи не відмовлюсь від того.
Я - людина, яка не міняє прапор в залежності від моди.
І так само, казали в ЗМІ, ви 15 років знаєте Володимира Зеленського,
а зараз складається враження, що між Офісом Президента і мером Києва точаться суперечки.
Мені дуже важко тут коментувати...
Я вважаю, що за такими коментарями..
Саме тому, що я товаришую і дружу і з одним, і іншим, я вважаю,
що буде дуже нечесно коментувати цю ситуацію з мого боку.
Але ж, знаєте, є дуже велика різниця: посада і людина.
І коли президент мене запросив в команду, то перше, що я сказав:
Володимире Олександровичу, я людина, яка працювала з Кличком, я з ним дружу.
Вас це не лякає?
Він сказав: я ціную, що ти чесно про це сказав.
Але коментувати…
Я вважаю, що це не моя справа.
Якби це був конфлікт МОЗу, наприклад,
і департаменту охорони здоров'я міста Києва, -
це те, на чому я розуміюся,
це те, що мене стосується, я б коментував.
Відносини Офісу президента і КМДА - це не до мене.
Як минуло все у Трускавці? Ваші враження?
Чи це було виправдано? Тренування? Це було більше тренування чи team building?
Дивіться, це було навчання.
Це було не тренування, це було навчання.
Я втомився.  Було таке враження, що я десь сім днів пахав.
Я давно так не втомлювався, як от саме за ці сім днів,
бо ми починали о 9-й ранку, а о 10-й вечора закінчували.
Ми здавали іспити, ми писали контрольні, ми грали.
Наша команда - це був суд України,
а були команди: партія “Слуга народу”, партія “Голос”.
Коли до нас було звернення від партії “Слуга народу”,
ми вийшли із заявою,
що партія “Слуга народу” чинить на політичний тиск на незалежний суд.
Це дійсно гра і ця гра, знаєте,
була як закріплення того, що ми навчались.
Приїжджали дуже поважні спікери.
Той самий (Віктор) Пинзеник був, Льоша Гончарук.
І найголовніше: 255 людей не могли бути між собою знайомі всі.
Тим більше, що це і мажоритарники, ті хто пройшов за списком.
Ми почали товаришувати, ми пізнали одне одного.
Ми сформували групу, яка зайде в Комітет охорони здоров’я.
Тобто група комітету від “Слуги народу” вже є.
Бо на початку ви говорили..
Ви питали, чи є голова Комітету.
Я вам кажу: ні, а група людей, які висловили бажання
як народні депутати, обрані,
зайти саме в медичний комітет,  - є.
Є перші законодавчі ініціативи?
Законодавчих ініціатив дуже багато.
І зміни в діюче законодавство, і закони,
які треба прийняти в найближчий час, щоб не зупиняти трансформацію.
Є дуже багато речей. Ми зараз співпрацюємо навіть з Кабміном, який ще не пішов,
з Мінфіном, бо розуміємо, що якщо Мінфін не змінить
у бюджет наступного року ці відсотки від ВВП, то будуть проблеми.
Для мене не мета бути депутатом, якби я хотів бути депутатом..
першу пропозицію я отримав ще в 1994 році.
Це хто?
Це Леонід Данилович.
Це не було метою для мене ніколи.
Я і так нормально заробляю, мені для цього не треба було бути депутатом.
Ми зараз перебуваємо у клініці “Борис”. Це ваш особистий кабінет був?
Ні, мій особистий кабінет був поруч.
Сьогодні це я попросив нових власників в оренду цей кабінет,
щоб тут була моя громадська приймальня народного депутата.
26 років я віддав цій клініці,
дуже важко відійти назовсім від неї.
Знаходячись тут, у цій будівлі, це такий перехідний період.
Я попросив, нові власники погодились, і я їм дуже вдячний за це.
Пане Михайле, дякую Вам за інтерв’ю.
Прошу.